With so many awesome Marvel movies and television
shows on the horizon, it can be hard to keep
up with the comic juggernaut's ever-growing
entertainment roster.
Fear not: We're here to give you a glimpse
of all the upcoming Marvel projects outside
of and beyond the MCU's upcoming Phase 4.
Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D. has improved steadily
while seeming to perpetually be on the bubble;
it's been in real danger of cancellation by
ABC on multiple occasions, but has always
received a stay of execution from corporate
parent Disney.
Season 5 ended on a note of relative finality,
so it surprised pretty much everyone when
the show was re-upped not only for a sixth
season, but a seventh.
It was, in fact, the very first series to
be slotted by the network for 2020.
At San Diego Comic-Con in July 2019, Marvel
TV head Jeph Loeb confirmed that the seventh
season would be the last.
Both seasons would be slightly truncated,
featuring 13 episodes as opposed to the standard
22 of previous seasons.
In the interest of forging a lean and mean
narrative, Season 6 has chosen to forgo any
reference to the larger Marvel Cinematic Universe,
up to and including the world-changing events
of Avengers: Infinity War and Avengers: Endgame,
to focus on telling its own story.
The season has focused on the organization's
rebuilding period under new leadership, as
Phil Coulson was confirmed to have died shortly
after the events of Season 5, but this rebuilding
is disrupted by the appearance of mysterious,
interdimensional hostiles led by a man who
happens to looks exactly like Coulson.
It seems certain that S.H.I.E.L.D.'s writers
already have a pretty good idea how it will
all play out going into next year's seventh
season, but as for the rest of us, we'll just
have to wait to find out.
The SUMC, or Sony Universe of Marvel Characters,
if you're not into the whole brevity thing,
was born of Sony Pictures' deal with Marvel
Studios, which allowed Marvel to integrate
Spider-Man into the MCU.
In exchange, Sony continues to produce ol'
Web-head's MCU-set solo outings, and also
has free rein to develop its own universe
based on ancillary Spider-Man characters.
This universe's inaugural effort, 2018's Venom,
cleaned up at the box office while satisfying
fans of the character left cold by Topher
Grace's unfortunate portrayal in Sam Raimi's
Spider-Man 3.
After that somewhat unexpected success, Sony
was quick to fast-track another Spidey-related
property that had been gestating since 2017.
That would be Morbius, based on the "living
vampire" and frequent Spider-Man nemesis who
first appeared in the pages of Marvel comics
in 1971.
The flick will star Jared Leto as Dr. Michael
Morbius, a brilliant biochemist whose attempts
to cure his own potentially fatal blood disease
with an experimental treatment, involving
the blood of vampire bats, go predictably
awry, transforming him into a superpowered
ghoul who must consume human blood to survive.
Daniel Espinosa directs from a script by Lost
in Space co-creators Matt Sazama and Burk
Sharpless.
We'll see if the SUMC can establish a dark,
horror-tinged streak when the movie hits screens
on July 31, 2020.
While nearly all of the upcoming Marvel projects
presented at SDCC had either long been rumored
or actually confirmed, there was a single
outlier that came as a complete shock to the
crowd.
To conclude the panel, Kevin Feige presented
two-time Academy Award winning actor Mahershala
Ali, whose scintillating performance as the
villain Cottonmouth was the best part of the
Marvel Netflix series Luke Cage.
Feige then announced that Ali would star in
the title role in an MCU incarnation of Blade,
and jaws throughout Hall H could be heard
hitting the floor as far away as L.A.
"What is that?"
The first movie adaptation of Blade, released
in 1998 and starring Wesley Snipes as the
half human-half vampire hero, is sometimes
considered to be the first modern superhero
film.
The flick spawned two sequels, and for virtually
the entire existence of the MCU, fans have
been wondering if the "Daywalker" would ever
get his time to shine in the MCU.
Feige put that speculation to rest in dramatic
fashion, and the involvement of the immensely
talented Ali is nothing short of a coup.
No further casting or plot details were announced,
but there is one bit of bad news: Feige confirmed
that Blade will not hit screens until the
MCU's Phase 5.
Call it the great Gunn-troversy of 2018.
In July of that year, the news broke that
James Gunn, writer and director of the beloved
Guardians of the Galaxy franchise, had been
let go from the third installment over a series
of old tweets that had been dug up by conservative
pundits.
Guardians fans were up in arms, but a silver
lining came in August, when it was announced
that Gunn's completed script would be used.
The search was on for a new director, a search
that continued right up until March of 2019,
when Disney put an end to the whole kerfuffle
by seemingly saying "the hell with it" and
re-hiring Gunn.
The nearly year-long impasse will have the
effect of delaying Vol. 3 for a bit, as it
didn't take Gunn long after his canning to
find another gig, at rival Warner Bros., writing
and directing a reimagined Suicide Squad for
DC.
Marvel Studios has agreed to wait patiently
until Gunn's work on that film, which is slotted
for release in the summer of 2021, is done
before putting Vol. 3 into production, meaning
that we're not likely to see it hit the big
screen until at least 2022.
Marvel isn't playing coy about King T'Challa's
second solo outing.
It doesn't have an official title or release
date, but Black Panther 2 has been officially
confirmed by the studio, not exactly a huge
surprise, as the original became one of the
highest-grossing films of all time and Marvel's
first to receive serious Oscar consideration,
winning three for its original score, costume
design, and production design.
Not only is the sequel officially happening,
but Feige revealed to Entertainment Weekly
that the concept is already coming together
nicely.
He told EW:
"One of the favorite pastimes at Marvel Studios
is sitting around on a Part One and talking
and dreaming about what we would do in a Part
Two.
There have been plenty of those conversations
as we were putting together the first Black
Panther.
We have ideas and a pretty solid direction
on where we want to head with the second one."
Writer/director Ryan Coogler is officially
on board, and while nothing is confirmed,
it's expected that the principal cast, including
Chadwick Boseman, Lupita Nyong'O and Danai
Gurira, will also return.
It's even been rumored that Michael B. Jordan's
Erik Killmonger could return in some capacity,
despite being left in no condition to do so
at the end of Black Panther.
In light of the megabucks that film made,
we're likely to get additional details on
this highly-anticipated sequel sooner rather
than later.
Given the fact that it kicked off a universe
of Spider-Man characters which will not, so
far as we now know, actually feature Spider-Man,
the success of Sony's Venom was a bit of a
shock.
Anchored by Tom Hardy's completely bonkers
performance, the film cleaned up at the worldwide
box office of the tune of $855 million, making
a sequel inevitable.
Of course, having learned a few tricks from
Marvel Studios, Sony made sure to go ahead
and set one up in advance with a post-credits
scene featuring Woody Harrelson as Cletus
Kasady, the psychopathic serial killer who
will go on to bond with Carnage, the Venom
symbiote's offspring.
Venom 2 was at one time assumed to be the
"Untitled Sony/Marvel sequel" which the studio
had slotted for an October 2020 release, but
that is no longer set in stone due to the
departure of Venom director Ruben Fleischer,
who has his hands full with the long-awaited
sequel to his 2009 classic Zombieland.
But the second go-round for the Lethal Protector
is still in active development, with original
scribe Kelly Marcel already drafting a screenplay,
and Hardy set to return along with co-star
Michelle Williams.
Plot details are sketchy, but one thing is
certain: just as Kasady promised in that stinger…
"When I get outta here, and I will, there's
gonna be Carnage."
…Variety confirmed in January 2019 that
Harrelson's murderous symbiote will be Venom
2's main villain.
It's a little tough to believe that at this
point, Spider-Man has a rich cinematic history
spanning almost 20 years and nearly a dozen
feature films, yet here we are.
For all the box office bucks raked in by Sam
Raimi's trilogy, the Amazing Spider-Man reboot
series, and the MCU iteration ably portrayed
by Tom Holland, none of those films were able
to do what Sony Pictures Animation's Spider-Man:
Into the Spider-Verse did: score an Academy
Award.
2018's Best Animated Feature winner is considered
by some to be among the best, if not the best,
superhero films ever made, with its supremely
innovative animation style and focus on its
eclectic cast of alternate-universe Spider-People.
It's so singular a cinematic achievement that
it seems like its success would be impossible
to duplicate, but darned if Sony isn't going
to try.
The Spider-Verse sequel will center on the
burgeoning romantic relationship between Miles
Morales and Gwen Stacy, a.k.a. Ghost-Spider,
and, according to co-director Rodney Rothman,
will take place two years after the events
of the first film.
Additional plot details are still a mystery,
but Sony Pictures' Amy Pascal has let slip
that the sequel will feature even more female
versions of Spidey besides Gwen Stacy and
Peni Parker.
In fact, it will serve to set up a spin-off
film focused entirely on these characters
in the form of a similarly animated film that
will introduce classic Spider-Woman Jessica
Drew along with Cindy Moon, also known as
Silk.
Disney's acquisition of Fox gave the House
of Mouse a 60% stake in Hulu, and even before
the deal closed, the streamer was looking
to expand its Marvel offerings beyond its
hit original series Runaways.
The first set of announced new projects, however,
came as a bit of a surprise: four adult animated
series centered on some of the quirkier characters
in Marvel lore, which will, of course, cross
over for a team-up special.
All co-produced by TV EVP Jeph Loeb, each
series features creative talent just as eclectic
as the characters themselves.
Get ready for: The Tigra and Dazzler Show,
produced by Chelsea Handler; Hit-Monkey, courtesy
of Blades of Glory writing team Josh Gordon
and Will Speck; M.O.D.O.K., which will be
written and produced by Patton Oswalt; and,
wait for it…
"What do you let him lick you like that for?
Gross."
That's right!
Kevin Smith will be helming Howard the Duck.
Obviously, each series looks to be aiming
for its own distinct comedic vibe, but Loeb
will be tasked with bringing them all together
for The Offenders, a one-off special in which
all of these weird characters will team up
to tackle a common enemy which threatens the
world.
Marvel's first foray into animated comedy
looks interesting, to say the least, and finally,
we'll hopefully get a version of Howard the
Duck to once and for all purge the memory
of that terrible, terrible 1986 film.
"Now, you and Baby Face are going to beat
it, right, Mr. Zits?
Before I get really mad!"
While a sequel to the billion-dollar-plus
grossing Captain Marvel seems like a foregone
conclusion, it has also yet to be confirmed.
According to leaker extraordinaire "Wardell,"
the wheels are turning.
Star Brie Larson is reported to have signed
a seven-picture deal with Marvel, and it sure
seems unlikely that the studio's brass would
be content to simply have Carol Danvers pop
up in other characters' movies after her first
solo vehicle's stellar box office performance.
Interestingly, "Wardell" isn't the only leaker
to have claimed inside knowledge about Captain
Marvel 2.
A Redditor posting under the name TheMarvelScoopMaster
asserted that the sequel will take place during
Avengers: Endgame's five-year time jump, and
will see Carol Danvers tangle with the interdimensional
cyborg Michael Korvac, a character with a
history in the comics stretching back to 1975,
who had dealings with the likes of the Grandmaster
and Doctor Strange.
The Redditor claims that Danvers will investigate
a Kree "secret weapon" that turns out to be
Korvac, and that the two will initially bond
over having both been unwilling Kree experiments.
But then, Korvac will betray Danvers, and
the two will end up doing battle in the film's
climax.
Of course, this is merely an unsubstantiated
rumor, so be sure to take it with a grain
of salt.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.